[Music]
strength training is an important
component of a fitness regimen one way
to build strength is to lift weights or
exercise on machines that provide
resistance when users pull push or lift
typically weights produce that
resistance but some machines use a
completely different system this
exercise machine doesn't have the
typical stack of weights instead the
handles are connected by a rope and
pulley system to a pneumatic cylinder
which creates resistance this
computer-guided laser cuts many of the
parts out of sheet steel it can make
complex cuts which are accurate within
100 microns the width of two human hairs
the parts go into a vibrating tumbler
filled with ceramic stones and water the
stones rub against the parts removing
what's called scale a flaky substance
produced on the surface of the steel by
the heat of the laser and oxygen in the
air a worker clamps the parts for the
trainers power module onto a welding
fixture
the fixture is on a robotic cell the
cell rotates delivering the parts to the
robot which proceeds to weld them
together
welding the power module takes 14
minutes when the robot completes the
welding the cell returns the fixture to
the worker who inspects the module
thoroughly then transfers it to the
finishing area a worker grinds the welds
flat then with a finer grinding disc
smoothes them out so that they won't
show once the steel is painted after
washing the module an iron phosphate a
worker applies a positive electrical
charge to the module and a negative one
to the powder paint opposite charges
attract drawing the paint particles onto
the surface in an even coat then the
worker bakes the paint onto the steel in
an oven elsewhere in the factory another
worker drills a 12 inch deep hole into a
cylinder rod the rod is steel the piston
on its end aluminum he inserts the
cylinder rod into the cylinder also made
of aluminum then carefully inserts a
sensor rod into the cylinder rods hole
the sensor relays the cylinders position
to the machines computer snap rings hold
the parts together
after a paintjob inspection the trainer
is ready for assembly first comes the
decals the assembler wets the surface
with soapy water then applies them once
the decals are partially dry he gingerly
removes the transfer tape and inspects
for bubbles or gaps next he installs the
machines computer it calculates the
power produced with each pull on the
handles then he installs what's called
the accumulator tank which stores the
air for the return stroke of the handles
he installs the cylinder the bottom is
assembled to a central pulley that
connects to both handles the top
connects to the accumulator tank with an
air hose the amount of force is
determined by how much air pressure the
user lets in when pushing the yellow
resistance control buttons the buttons
are attached to air hoses and wire to
the computer the assembler routes a 26
foot long rope through the central fully
and through the machines 12 additional
pulleys the configuration is designed to
enable a wide range of exercises
after closing up the power module with a
cover panel and installing the two
height adjustable arms the assembler
installs a swiveling pulley on each arm
and ties what's called a clevis to the
end of each rope the clevis holds a wide
range of other attachments once assembly
is complete an inspector checks for any
aesthetic or functional defects he sets
a resistance level then pulls on the
handles to make sure the cylinder sensor
is reading correctly pulling a handle
pushes the rod into the cylinder forcing
the piston against the incoming air
pressure supplied by a compressor
because this power trainer uses air
rather than weights to produce
resistance
users can workout at faster speeds which
produces higher power